i appreciate you
talking to me because i was uh very
excited
about the movie and the character i also
cover theme parks i've
been going to disneyland since i was a
child
so this whole the idea of this movie was
so much fun to me
and i love that uh the changes
that they made to this character oh good
good to hear
there has been a lot of talk about how
problematic this character is for a long
time so it was nice to i love the whole
like
female energy they're bringing to some
of the rides at disneyland now
yes me too i think it's fantastic
i'm curious when this roll of trader sam
in
a big disney movie based on the jungle
cruise ride
came your way how much were you actually
told about it
how did they describe the character what
what did they tell you
well you know um there were very little
things that they told me
um i knew they were uh
still deciding if they wanted a woman or
a man to play it so i know they were
casting both
actors female and male i knew the
character a little bit
because of disney you know because as
you
the first time i came to disneyland i
think it was probably the first or the
second ride i jumped in
so i remember the character i knew it
was going to be different
and i don't exactly recall the
description
in the in the casting but it was um
it made illusion that the character was
a little bit of a merchant
a little bit of an inventor a little bit
of a chief of a tribe it was a little
eccentric
uh funny you know and uh and a good
business
but you know he got a good business
sense but it also
had you know the way i read it it read
to me that it could be a bit eccentric
you know and um and i love that i
love not only that he was taking care of
his people you know his drive
or her tribe in this case but you know
at the beginning as i say with you know
if it was a man or a woman
um and i love this this creativity of
the character you know how he could
turn something into a business and he
can make something into
that you know use something for
something it was not meant to be used
so that creative part and the part of
being protective
to to the tribe and trying to provide
for them and help them
you know that was two of the things that
i like most about the character
and uh and yeah i i mean the idea
that i could potentially be cast to play
a character
in a disney ride it's quite fantastic
for me
as um as a little girl that came from
mexico
to finally go to disneyland for the
first time in my life at 11 or 12 years
old
and to think that i was going to
possibly be able to do a character like
that
was quite uh fantastic and it's cool
because it is one of those classic rides
that was there
on opening day and it's a ride everybody
goes on because it's not too scary
and i just i think it's it's really fun
that they were able to do this
with it and and then still you know be
able to see
that there are changes that need to be
made with a ride that's older
so i i just i love that yeah yeah thank
you thank you for saying that
it also seems really fun to get to be a
part of
a big epic adventure it is
it is a lot of fun you know i um
i didn't thought i got the movie because
i did the audition and of course this is
one of the characters that come once in
a lifetime in an actor's life
and you want it but you know you don't
know i i
work hard and i'm like i hope they like
the audition and that's all you can hope
for you know you
you know you're gonna be competing with
actors that are
equally as good or much better than you
you know um so you just really throw it
out there and just have to let go
because you cannot worry about that too
much but something really funny
happened you know i auditioned for this
role and like two to three days later
i was in mexico city and a dear dear
friend of mine which is a fantastic
actor very he has done a lot of
work all over you know here in the
states and in mexico
he was auditioning for this part and he
told me he's like i'm auditioning for a
really interesting part in disney movie
and i say um i know which one because
you know that wasn't
and he's like how do you know i said
because they auditioned for that too
he's like but you're a woman i say yeah
you're a man and here we are you know i
don't know who they're gonna choose but
it was funny and
he's such a fantastic actor it would
have been very interesting to see him
if he could have been mailed the
character but you know
um i got lucky and then so after that
happened
the thing is i thought okay well it's
probably not gonna be for me they're
seeing
you know because i really respect him as
an actor and i'm sure they were seeing a
lot of
great people so you know i let go of
that and i went on a family vacation
with my son
and i was in barcelona which is actually
the city where
uh joe mikulet serra is from you know
and they call me and they're like well
director wants to talk to you
so i talk with uh jama and uh
i i didn't know you know he was very
nice he explained me what he wanted what
they liked and that was that and then
like three days later i
got the call that i got to play this
role
and it was um was very surreal
uh the whole thing you know just go
there and be able to play this character
and see
you know dre dwayne dresses keeper and
the whole jungle cruise thing and
the sets are incredible um it was
incredible like you know that the
tagline of the movie says
um the adventure of a lifetime i felt
like it was kind of like my adventure of
a lifetime yeah
yeah because it seems like you know as
an actor you just you want to take one
box
that's like you know either a good
script or a good director or a good cast
and you you have all of those and this
big adventure
and then the disney connection and the
ride i mean it just seems like so many
cool and fun elements at once and you
know the most amazing thing is not only
that like of course you have all these
check boxes you know that are like
great but on top of that i got to work
with people that are very kind
very generous and very supportive which
is not always the case
um you know like you can find all sorts
of people but in
case of jungle cruise i mean i've been
very lucky because i mostly i'm very
lucky with the cast and the people i
work with
um but especially in jungle cruise the
way emily and dwayne and jack and
gentleman
disney received me and they were so kind
and supportive and
and and i'm not just saying this because
you know i know a lot of times
you guys as journalists must hear like
oh okay another cast that really
is luck but we really you know when you
see dwayne and emily and jack
like joking around and the kind of
chemistry they have in the movie
it's real though you know it really
happened behind the scenes so i had like
the most fun because i would just look
at them or or you know sometimes
participate in in this
this great rapport that they had and um
and that's fun you know so
it was like it was one of those
wonderful projects
was there also a process for figuring
out the look of the character once you
had been
cast did you try various looks before
the one we see in the film or was there
always a very clear idea
of what she would wear and how she would
look well you know paco delgado and joel
harlow they are fantastic they're really
masters of what they do and they were
very
i mean the design of the character was
already done they were
adjusting little things but what i must
say
not only they were incredibly prepared
and they had everything designed
they were also very open and general so
like if i had
something you know like that was not
comfortable or that i couldn't move or
or that i wanted like like um a
suggestion or something they always
incorporate that
uh my character is very gestural you
know it moves a lot the hands
um so i was talking about it with joel
or our makeup designer and
he was like okay so maybe i'll put more
stuff in the hands and that idea of
putting the eye here like you see
in the poster of course that's his so
they really are so good at what they do
you know they know
that an actor needs to make their design
because we do it together you know it's
not
just an actor it's like a whole bunch of
people working so this character can
be seen the way it is and we all are
very respectful of one another
but i remember paco was the first guy i
met
you know baca delgado costume designer
and
i saw this incredible amount of
pictures and paintings and costumes that
he was thinking for the character and i
was just
really amazed i really loved all of them
you know
and we were trying some of the costumes
and some things were a little difficult
to move and he was like
no no no no worry let me adjust that and
he would do like lose something
move here move that and then i would be
able to move so
that's what makes them great not only
they are creative and they can but they
also know how to work with actors
and how to help us you know create the
character
and and move with their costumes or with
their makeup
i love that we get a real sense too of a
history and a backstory with
this character and with her relationship
with frank
did you think much about like what she's
doing when we don't get to see her what
kind of life she lives when she's not
scared absolutely i thought about it a
lot you know i thought that she
likes um one of the things she
loves doing i think is experimenting
with things
you know like she would find like
something an expedition left
i don't know like maybe some eyeglasses
you know and
she would find 10 000 different uses for
the eyeglasses
i also could imagine her very well like
uh training and seeing how people are
trained in the village
playing with kids you know because she
was a little bit of a kid herself
um because of this creativity i also can
imagine her like sitting and meditating
looking at the stars
you know i'm thinking of um either
some really deep philosophical question
that she doesn't even know how deep it
is
to thinking of how she's gonna trick
frank again
you know and how are they can make a
better deal and how can they
you know um i can see her totally like
worrying about what's going on like in
in the amazons in those days it wasn't
as terrible as it is now
but i could see that she was someone
that could see a head
you know and i also um could imagine her
dreaming about traveling you know she
she loved that
and she loved animals she loved food for
example
so all those things i i really imagined
in her world
and uh and one of the things that helped
most
uh and i wasn't expecting it as such
the first time i saw the tree where she
lives with the village
literally i'm not kidding you i almost
felt like crying it was that
beautiful you know it was lit in such a
way
and i it really you step into it and i'm
like okay that's her world
it really felt like that so i remember
telling that to dwayne and to our
producers and say
i'm sorry guys i'm sure you heard this
before but this is really fantastic
i was very very excited about it they
were probably like yeah we know it's
fantastic we work hard at it
you know but i was um yeah i was very
surprised
at the feelings you've also joined the
final season of ozark
and yes since you don't typically get to
read scripts for an entire
season of a tv show ahead of time what
made you want to be
a part of that series was it
specifically the character
or had you seen the show well
it's not that i i i went and i
tried i wish they invited me to audition
and i was just hoping for the best
you know like it's not like i choose
projects i get
i i'm not i mean i'm not in that
position um
but i do get um to audition for great
shows of course i had seen ozark
and i loved it and i love lauren i love
jason you know i
i followed laura linney as an actor
she's incredibly talented and
and inspiring and so when i auditioned
for
for ozark you know it was just exciting
to be invited to audition for them
um when they gave me the role it was
incredibly
exciting and it's it's funny because
it's very very different from what i do
in
in jungle you know so as an actor it's a
really
great gift if you're given the
opportunity to play
characters that are so um incredibly
different
um it's it's really a gift for an actor
so i'm very grateful for that
what can you say to tease the final
season and your character and how she's
gonna
fit into this world well you know i
i can't tell much i can tell you that
it's gonna be a season that
is gonna really blow everyone away uh
they're gonna love it
you know it's funny because um most of
the time you don't get the scripts but
little by little but they
have worked so hard in the show and
they're so precise
that they send me the scripts and it's a
big
you know it's a big bunch of scripts to
read
and i was like oh my god i hope i can
finish this on time
i literally read them in two nights
that's how good they were
like i was reading and i'm like oh my
god no are they oh my god
like i was really so if that was my
first reaction when i read the scripts
i think that once you see them on screen
you're really gonna go crazy like
everybody will
and the thing is they put it's not only
great writing
and great actors and everybody's good in
the show
it's also and i i saw that when i met
our showrunner and
and laura and jason i mean and chris
the heart they put into the work and
it's the same with jungle cruise
you know if you see dwayne if you see so
every
single show or film that i'm blessed to
work with
um that is successful i think a lot of
it has to do not only with the quality
but also with the heart
that and the soul that people are really
putting into it
you know that that cannot be faked
people can see it
and sense it and that's why i think even
though they're very different they're
both very successful because of that
aside from all the other things what's
it like to join
such a popular show and to do so in its
final season
does it make things more nerve-wracking
is it more reassuring
do you always get nervous on a new
project i always get nervous the first
day
you know i always get nervous the first
day especially if i haven't worked with
a cast
and of course you know um as i say i i'm
a big fan of laura as an actress and the
moment i met her
she was so warm you know she opened her
arms like that and she said veronica
welcome to ozark
i fell in love with her right away i
said oh my god this is gonna be fun
and the same with jason and with chris
and with everybody else you know it was
it is a bit um nerve-wracking because
they are just so good at it and you just
want to do good
you know it was the same with emilian
duane i was like oh my god and disney
they're so good at what they do and they
are
so precise and you just want to honor it
and you just want to be good so that
puts a little bit of pressure on but you
know once you start working it's just
it's just fun because they're just so
good at it so you just
you just need to be prepared and and be
ready with what you have to do and then
they
they will help you out and it's it's
great
how was your experience on perry mason
which is another show that was a real
surprise to me
because i went into it thinking it might
be one thing
and then i just i fell in love with the
look of the show especially being
from los angeles getting to see los
angeles in a way that i haven't really
seen it yeah i mean that was another one
of these
incredibly blessed projects you know
like um i read
um the character of lupe and when the
hbo sent
um the casting they were really open for
uh different ages you know they were
casting actors from 30 something to
to 40 50 something and i thought i would
not really have much of a chance because
uh matthew rhys is younger than me and
you know
um not always is that easy that we get
these roles
as older actresses even though thank god
that is changing
very necessary um but i knew it's hbo
and i know they're they're
they're so good and so you know so
professional with uh
every decision and i thought you know if
they like it
if they think it it works even if i'm
older or younger
they will just give it to me because it
works so i don't have to worry about
that
i knew that i also thought i might not
get a chance
um but even if i don't just to audition
for this role is going to be fun so um
i auditioned for it and i i luckily got
it
and then i got to meet um matthew ruiz
because most of my scenes are with
matthew and tim van patten
and again you know it was kind of like
like what happened with jungle and with
ozark
great people doing great work being
incredibly kind
generous um supportive you know
and it was it wasn't amazing so i'm
getting spoiled because i'm really
getting to work
with people that are at on on the top of
their game but they're also
so genuinely supportive and nice and
happy to have um
a latina actress in the show and happy
to
to work with different kind of actors
and i think that's very
inspiring and it's very important what
was it like to
shoot the sex scene in season one i mean
was that
do you have a laugh when you do
something like that yes you do
because you know first of all it's
incredibly choreographed
incredibly like i know everybody
whenever we get asked these questions
all the actors say it's very technical
and everybody rolls their eyes and like
yeah sure it is
it really is you know and especially
with um
that scene because we had to break the
bed literally
but we really have to figure out a way
to do it
and um and it was very funny when we
were rehearsing because
we just got into all these like
positions and trying to figure out a way
that it would be believable that they
can break the bath
so we we laugh a lot but you know one of
the the loveliest things
is um matthew was always
always like are you comfortable are you
comfortable
do you are you okay do you feel okay i
mean it was lovely you know so
um we had a lot of fun doing that scene
and yeah it is very technical nowadays
we have in production what you what it's
called an intimacy coordinator and it's
someone that's
there to make sure everything is okay
and you're comfortable and everybody's
being heard and all the things are
precisely done but yeah we rehearse that
scene for around
two or three hours and then the day
after we shot it so
yeah that was fun and people seem to
like it it's a funny
you know it's a and i like the way um
you know the woman takes control i think
it's important to see
all sorts of scenes uh when when you're
watching sex scenes
will you be in season two of the show
have you had conversations about
returning
well you know they they will do a season
two
and uh we all were happy i know they
were happy with my work and i was
certainly
incredibly happy with being part of it
so of course if they would invite me i
would love to do it
but you know they're figuring out the
the whole second season so
i guess we'll hear about it you know if
they if they need me for the season
but if i don't get invited i'm still
gonna watch the show and applaud it
because i love everyone and i think it's
a
it's a great show it's very well done
yeah and it's beautiful to look at i
mean it was just
it was i'm also a fan of that los
angeles you know
so yeah for me that was it was beautiful
to see how they rebuilt so many parts of
the city
and then go visit them and see you know
yeah
i'm a big fan of of that era
it sounds like your role in talking in
the winter soldier was greatly affected
by kovid
how much more had you shot than what we
got to see well i was hired to be
in four episodes so we went to prague to
do that
and i finished the four episodes but
then
actually the day that i finished
shooting my last episode
that day that was the day that
everything got closed for covet so it
was
you know incredibly strange for
everybody because we still couldn't
believe it
you know we had no exp previous
experience none of us
all over the world of what happened and
we couldn't believe it it almost felt
kind of surreal so i remember arriving
to the hotel and then they said okay we
need to get everybody out
you know this is very serious and um
they didn't finish that that show in
that moment they had to go back
and do it and then at the end of the day
you know they have to
to reconstruct and rearrange the show
and in that reconstruction and
rearrangement my character
got to play less so i'm only in i think
one or two very very little scenes
and they did a great show you know but
everybody was adapting to the
circumstances and i think
they did wonderfully the show is very
liked by by
the audience and maybe one day i'll get
to play that character again or maybe
they'll do something with it but even if
not
i totally understand and support what
they did because we were all trying to
do the best we could with what we had
you know and that's um that was so many
hours of work
so much time that whatever they needed
to do
in terms of editing to make the show
work for the audience that's absolutely
the right call
you know i still had a wonderful time
shooting there
i got to visit prague which i have never
been before and i love the
city and everyone was was kind and it
was a wonderful
two weeks that i was there and um and
i'm so glad to hear the show is doing
great
yeah i mean it was such an odd situation
because you know when production shut
down everybody was saying like oh it'll
just be a couple weeks and then
it sort of switched and everybody
thought well maybe nothing will ever be
able to get back into production again
i mean there were just those times where
nobody knew what was happening so
that was one of the shows that seemed to
really be like
heavily in the middle of all of that
yeah and
i mean what is that a situation where
like do they
let you know like did they call and
explain all of that to you like how did
you find out about well
they are they are very decent you know
they didn't they did
uh i knew what was happening because you
know i was there
and then they did call my agent and say
listen we love veronica but this is what
happened
and um and we look forward to work with
her again and that's more than a lot of
companies would do you know
marvel and disney do take care of their
talent and at least
in my case i had a wonderful experience
with both of them which is the same
um and but i remember they they give a
quick call to my agent and i really
appreciated it because they really don't
have to
you know they are solving bigger
problems like they have a huge
production
with a lot of people pandemic on top and
they still have the time to say
hey just tell the actress that this is
what happened like i would be fine
either way
you know but i really appreciated the
the call but
i totally totally understand and believe
me we're all trying to do the best we
can
with everything that's happening you
know so
yeah you're doing projects that are all
over the map
as far as genre and the types of
characters that you're playing
at this point in your life and career
what do you look for
is there something that's most important
to you does it start with the script is
there anything that
is an absolute no absolute no for you
how do you approach that
well i am i absolutely
i like characters that are
well written you know that's one thing
that for me is very important how well
written is a character
if it's rounded believable all that and
of course i love working with people i
admire that i think
i can learn from and that can
provide like a challenge a professional
challenge to learn
to be a better actor i'm very curious
about all sorts of uh generous and and
media you know um and the only the
absolute no for me
would be this respect you know when
there's a set
or someone that is disrespectful to
anybody
um to people in general or their own
kind or they're like
uh that's a no-no for me like i don't
care who they are like i think
if we haven't heard right now that we
have to treat everybody with respect and
kindness
but luckily enough i never have to worry
about that i've been very very
blessed with that so now um i just want
characters that are challenging and take
me from one place to the spectrum to the
other
you know i um i would love to do
um a shakespearean character for example
you know it's something that i've never
done in film or in television
i did a little bit of theater like that
i would love to do
characters that require a lot of
physical um
work because let's face it i don't know
how much longer i can do that at 55
so i'd like to take it back i mean of
course we've seen helen mirren do
you know action and she's killing it and
she's gorgeous you know but
um i think she was gorgeous her whole
time it's not like i'm gonna turn into
helen mirren i wish
um yeah like like you know that and i i
would love to
to do characters in i would love to do
something that shot in a place i've
never been
you know just because you have a chance
to meet the people and to be
in that location so yeah but it's a good
story you know a good story that that
calls me
i mean i would be all for like a disney
plus series of trader sam
and like what her life is outsiders
right don't go crazy because i feel like
there's so much more story to tell with
her
yeah i mean i would love to do something
like that you know that would be like
an absolute gift to be able to explore a
character
that way and uh um i would be
i could only be so blessed if that
happened you know but
yeah i i think you know
after going through the pandemic i think
i've been an actor for over
30 years and every single thing i get
now
is i just see it as a gift you know and
i try to work very hard
and i try to honor it and i try to to do
the best i can
and uh and that's already a lot
well i love doing jungle cruise i
appreciate you talking to me about that
and everything else it's been so fun to
see like the female pirate that's been
added to the pirates of the caribbean
ride and now
a female trader sam i just think is is
really an awesome choice
yeah me too i love i love that disney is
doing that and
it's important you know it is really
important for
for women and for little girls
everywhere and
in general for everybody because it's
not only a woman thing i think
the more we treat each other with
equality and with respect the better we
all be
whether you're a man or a woman you know
so this is doing that part and i
and i love to be that i'm being part of
that so thank you so much
for the interview christina and and
thank you
so lovely to talk to you yeah thanks a
lot and i'll definitely be looking
forward to ozark so
thank you